hello Internet it's Q&A time first
question are memes the future of society
I think you met this as a joke but the
answer is yes the internet for memes is
the perfect petri dish gladiatorial
theatre and mutation chamber growing
selecting and randomizing the me missed
me meme in our minds society has always
been a war of memes but before it was
fought with sticks and stones the
Internet however has arms raced that
fight to trench warfare of meme driven
brains in many areas they've not yet
captured all fields of thought but I
fear the meme trenches will only expand
in a previous Q&A I was asked what topic
I've changed my mind on and the
unmitigated benefits of the Internet
sure is one of those things rate from
top to bottom
pancakes waffles french toasts if you
know you're at a great restaurant then
the ordering hierarchy is french toast
before waffles before pancakes if you're
at a restaurant of unknown quality the
hierarchy reverses pancakes are more
reliably consistent and thus can't reach
the repulsive troughs or sublime peaks
of french toast what makes you unique
compared to seven billion people on
earth in a world of billions no one is
unique if you could have a companion
animal like the golden compass what
would you have a chimpanzee daemon
maximize utility while minimizing
inconvenience what common life advice do
you disagree with do what you love and
her sister means follow your passion the
word passion here is a disgusting
perversion of language if you know words
mean things and yes there are people who
are passionate gross about their work
but guess what those kinds of people
don't need advice they're going to do
whatever they're passionate about anyway
so this advice is useless to those who
are its exemplars while being an T
useful to everyone else making most
people feel bad about their lives and
their work by setting an impossibly high
bar in life rather than expecting to
find a burning passion inside yourself
that you somehow don't know about
already because it doesn't exist it's
better and more useful to think of life
like fishing some spots are beautiful to
you and in some spots your skills will
catch fish others not but you can't know
where you'd like to spend time until you
go there and you can't know how many
fish you can catch there until you try
the younger you are the more time you
can spend sailing to different spots and
then the older you are the more time you
get to spend in places you know you like
refining your abilities to catch fish
there
did you have a point in life that turned
you around productivity wise if so what
changed and what contributed to that
change yes there was a time and an event
I drifted through school without
learning how to be organized because
despite what schools tell you about
preparing you for the real world they're
mostly a babysitting service obsessed
with an endless game of Trivial Pursuit
when school dumped me into the real
world I had no idea how to adult and
needed to figure it out fast the single
thing that changed me the most was
keeping a paper notebook in my pocket
and writing down my thoughts and simply
looking back at that notebook on a
regular basis that loop booted me into a
real human it's so simple but it comes
down to increasing communication between
the past present and future you that's
how you direct change in yourself over
time what motivates you to do anything
productive when everything is
meaningless anyway this if we all die
what's the point meme is a bad one for
brains like it's true that in the long
run we are all not but dust forgotten
forever but your present experiences are
real and they're all you'll ever have a
sunset doesn't need meaning to be
enjoyed the enjoyment is the meaning
using productivity to build a life you
want to live is intrinsically meaningful
despite abyss swallowing us all in the
end if you're not in a good place
there's lots of small stuff you can do
to start turning that around watch this
do the opposite what would you do if you
became immortal I'd live a really long
time on a Dungeons & Dragons alignment
chart where would you place yourself Oh
D&D alignment charts so fun because of
the endless disagreements over what the
words lawful cannot a good evil and
neutral mean you think it's obvious but
so does the guy you're arguing with
people might think I'm over here but I
might view myself as over here or
depending on how much you want to D&D
rules lawyer the word chaos maybe even
over here but the question ultimately
presupposes the lie that people are
consistent selves and in reality
ourselves are situational and everyone
is everything for a time or
to the right circumstances but that's no
fun it's easier and means e'er to put
people on a 2d grid and I've yet to see
a D&D alignment chart for YouTube who
among tubers is our lawful good and who
is our chaotic evil on the reddit I look
forward to seeing your 2d D&D
interpretations of the multi-faceted
people on this site you are allowed to
change the name of the seventh planet in
our solar system what would you call it
King George of course I'm still serious
about this mean hashtag seventh planet
King George if you could remove a single
trait or characteristic from human
beings as a species what would it be and
why human tribalism is a double-edged
sword there were fourteen thousand
questions submitted to this Q&A on my
the reddit and it's astounding to see
how many are really asking are you part
of my tribe or not and it's
disappointing to see how badly people
react when the answer is no even on the
most trivial of things
however tribalism is how we develop
teamwork and teamwork is how we build
civilizations but tribes are so often
motivated by the totem they construct of
the other tribe to yell at so if
tribalism and the teamwork it creates
could still exist when removing the
tendency to build totems to burn in
effigy I'd do that can you wear a hat
for the rest of the video ok what's your
opinion on whether Balrogs have wings ah
the great Balrog debate of 2000
the good reason my Balrog is drawn the
way it is the line from fellowship
breeds Gandalf enemy halted again facing
him and the shadow about the Balrog
reached out like - - wings unambiguous a
shadow that like wings isn't wings
they're metaphorical wings yet not two
paragraphs later Tolkien writes the
Balrog drew itself up to a great height
and its wings were spread from wall to
wall unambiguous wings or maybe not are
these wings the metaphorical wings from
but 12 sentences earlier well now this
has become an argument about how big the
room
is that these real or metaphorical wings
must stretch across asking did the
Balrog have wings the books have the
same answer as hey where did the orcs
come from day month year or month day
year your month day what are your
thoughts on thoughts who knows where
thoughts come from they just appear is
the glass half full or half empty
why must judgment be passed the glass is
this full how would you rule the world
with compassion and an iron fist am i
first no you were exactly ten thousand
forty fourth what have you read recently
any recommendations I'm glad you asked
never not act for today's sponsor is
audible who likes it when I recommend
books and will give you a free audiobook
with a 30-day trial at audible.com slash
gray related to that earlier question I
did recently read try b'bye Sebastian
Junger and it really changed my
perception on the experiences soldiers
have in war and how people act during
disaster and just in general how groups
survive when there's outside stresses
acting on them it's a thoughtful book
and it's also nice and short which is a
big advantage so I like tribe I
recommend it and if you want to give it
a try you can do so with audible they
have an unmatched library of audio books
and original audio shows you can listen
to audiobooks have added a lot to my
life and audible is where I get my
audiobooks from so you should give them
a try and go get your free audio book
maybe it's tribe but maybe it's
something else you want to listen to
with a 30-day trial at audible.com slash
gray thanks to audible for sponsoring
this episode and thank you to everyone
who submitted questions I'll see you
next time